it's a Hollywood Story again that I
don't really care about that much in
itself but I care about the political
implications Hugh Jackman and his wife
are divorcing after 27 years of marriage
I really like Hugh Jackman I think he is
a tremendous
not only actor but performer generally
I've seen this guy on Broadway he's just
he's just a tremendous
performer and he's always struck me as a
nice guy compared to the demons running
around Hollywood he seems relatively
normal and grounded and sort of nice and
he's just all around seems like a decent
fellow and so it's very sad
that this guy one of one of the things
that really spoke to his character is
that he had been married for 27 years by
Hollywood standards that is an eternity
that is
the longest marriage ever and now sadly
it seems they're going to split up and
here's the statement that they made
we have been blessed to share almost
three decades together
our journey now is Shifting and we have
decided to separate to pursue our
individual growth
this is what I can't stand about it
and you hear this again and again in
modern divorce statements they say Lord
well we're so happy what a wonderful
time we've spent together but now we're
going to have a conscious decoupling of
that time it's so wonderful to pursue
what really matters which is of course
our individual growth and so that's
really great and it's so happy no it's
not happy man it's a tragedy it's a
tragedy anytime a marriage breaks down
and you should be deeply sad we should
all be deeply sad about it because it's
a public matter because when you get
married you take a vow before a minister
and the public and God and you enter
into society because the fundamental
unit of society is the family and I get
that marriages break down and I get that
there's been divorce for a very very
long time there's been divorce for all
of history sometimes it's been illegal
and so the state is clamped down on it
and it happens less frequently in our
culture you can get divorced because you
don't like the way the wind is blowing
that day we have no fault divorce but
anytime it happens it's a tragedy
so even if you accept the fact that it
will happen
it's a very least you should say this is
sad we're sorry this happened but no we
can't do that anymore
we have to know it's Wonder it's
actually good it's good because we're
going to do the most important thing
which is pursue our individual growth
well you know you're not what is
conducive to your individual growth is
remaining married
that's what's conducive to it because
you're not just a free-floating atom in
outer space you're part of society
you're the social creature and the
political animal and so what did they
say why did it break down a spokesman
for the the jackmans
say that the writer's strike has
contributed to it because they've been
stuck around at home a little bit more I
guess and the the pandemic the lockdowns
and this is really really sad too
because I wonder of all of the terrible
things that came out of those completely
unnecessary lockdowns they were
politically necessary for the Liberals
they were financially beneficial to the
biggest corporations on Earth the the
lockdowns represented the largest shift
in wealth from the lower classes to the
upper classes ever in human history
but they were from a standpoint of
Public Health completely unnecessary
and what happened as a result people
didn't get to see their loved ones
before they died people didn't get to
bury their loved ones people put off
weddings people put off their school
people lost their graduations people
lost prom
and I wonder
how many marriages broke down because of
this
how many
when you upend all of the norms and
routines of society
things are going to break things did
break economically politically but all
the way down to the family how many
marriages broke up
because the Democrats wanted to lock the
country down
because there was an election the next
year
among perhaps other reasons but I think
that's probably Chief among them how
many right now text Knowles Canada
w-l-e-s to 98 98 98 Vladimir Putin
called the US Dollars drop in dominance
quote objective and irreversible as
Brazil Russia India China and South
Africa formally agreed to use local
currencies and trade instead of the US
dollar as demand for the dollar weakens
the buying power of the dollar weakens
that is why Birch gold is busier than
ever investors and Savers are looking to
harness the power of physical gold held
in a tax sheltered Ira you can too you
can protect your IRA or 401K by
diversifying with gold from Birch gold
as the US dollar continues to receive
pressure from foreign countries digital
currency and central banks arm yourself
with information on how to protect your
savings learn if gold is right for you
too text Knowles Canada wlas to 98 98 98
they will send you a free info kit on
gold with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless funds
store reviews I trust Birch gold to help
you diversify into gold if a central
bank digital currency becomes a reality
it'll be nice to have some gold to
depend on so text Knowles Canada wlas to
98 98 98 for you a few years maybe even
a few decades out of school and
wondering what did I even learn and what
was the point you might think to
yourself that you don't have time to
learn something new well if that's you
then know this you're not alone it's not
too late since 1844 Hillsdale College
has been providing education in faith
freedom and character they've taken some
of the core classes they teach on campus
and made them available for free online
for anyone who wants to learn that's
right for free there are 39 free courses
to choose from ranging from the U.S
Constitution the Book of Genesis to free
market economics they're easy to follow
they're self-paced so you can start
whenever you want in fact you can start
right now it's everything you need
all in one place no long-term commitment
let Hillsdale College be your guide as
all of the universities around America
collapse Hillsdale is one of the very
few beacons of Hope learn what you want
when you want go to hillsdale.edu
Knowles Canada wlas to enroll there's no
cost very easy to get started
hillsdale.edu Knowles to register
hillsdale.edu Knowles
speaking of breaking up
Republican Congressman Nancy mace
who is a liberal Republican but
sometimes she takes the right sides on
political fights she has gone on ABC
News and she has raised the prospect of
replacing Kevin McCarthy as speaker so
you've seen Matt Gates come out not just
Matt Gates but he most loudly and
prominently saying that he's gonna push
to ouist McCarthy a motion to vacate
could you see yourself under any
circumstances supporting emotion to
vacate it hasn't happened yet and I'm
not going to you know you know uh
comment on conjecture here either he's
going to file it or he's not if he's
going to do it put his money where his
mouth is I do hear that some votes might
be up for grabs because people will make
promises that have not been kept what
about your vote is it up for grabs
we'll see how it turns out but I will
tell you I'm one of those members who
made certain promises I've worked on
women's issues I've worked on issues you
know related to gun violence I feel are
very important and you know it's fallen
on deaf ears and if I if I give a
handshake to someone I expect them to
follow through with wow so you don't
rule out supporting that do you think I
I might you know what everything's on
the table at this point for me
good honor good honor I kind of like her
uh siding with the more conservative
members here and trying to get a little
bit of Leverage on the house speaker
I generally have thought McCarthy is
fine I thought he's a lot better than
John Boehner until I heard that story
that I mentioned yesterday that has not
been reported anywhere else that
McCarthy seems to be pushing
the vulnerable members of the Republican
caucus to lay off the Bud Light boycott
and I heard that story and then I heard
some of the evidence for it I heard
about the way he was doing it through
this supposedly private sector and I
thought that's not I hope that's not
true I certainly hope that's not true
and it's a miscommunication and they
just give it up that started to weaken
my general
feelings of Goodwill for Kevin McCarthy
but the question like the reason I can't
go all the way with the hardcore far
right wing extreme Republicans
on the on Kevin McCarthy's speakership
is my question which is
who follows him
who follows McCarthy
do I think McCarthy is some rock ribbed
right-wing conservative no I don't
but he's better than the last few
Republican speakers we've had
and my question is who else is it going
to be they remember they challenged
McCarthy for speaker
the the conservative members did but
then nobody wanted it some people said
maybe Jim Jordan will do it Jim Jordan
didn't want to do it
nobody wants that job it's probably the
most thankless job in Washington very
difficult to Wrangle a caucus like the
Republicans which is very diverse unlike
the Democrats which other than one or
two Representatives like quellar you
know who are a little more conservative
they're all just progressives they're
all just leftists in the Republican
party you got some liberals she got some
conservatives she got some more populous
type candidates you got some more
nationalist up candidates he's got more
globalist type so that's it's hard to
Wrangle them who comes next this is
always my question when the libs talk
about how they want to assassinate
Vladimir Putin so you want to take out
Putin okay who's next
who's next what what who you don't even
know anything about who's next you don't
know anything about Russia you just know
Putin's the bad guy so you want it but
sometimes the devil you know is better
than the devil you don't
remember Saddam Hussein was the devil
then what happened
when he left it wasn't necessarily an
improvement same thing with Mo Mark
Gaddafi in Libya certainly same thing
with Hosni Mubarak who was actually an
ally of ours in Egypt
who comes next
that's the question
we'll see but if McCarthy keeps playing
games like this
keeps trying to loosen the Bud Light
boycott I don't know
the pressure to boost him out of office
might increase boy what a great clip
that was it was good well I I agree now
if you want more of it you got to ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles show and we'll see you next time